and of course you and your husband you
were at the Royal Wedding I mean the
good one Harry and Megan there you are
walking in yeah yeah you weren't there
no no I didn't even know they got
married it's a lovely day it's an object
but how early do you have to get there I
varies I think I think we felt we should
get there quite early we also were
watching television and Oprah showed up
which when you realize that you're later
than Oprah so how long were you sitting
there before the thing I don't know I
mean I wasn't probably I wasn't counting
hours seriously how many hours were you
saying so we went in and it's a lovely
day you've dressed up it's all very thin
once you're in are you in are you on
lockdown then yeah yeah well yeah kind
of the main problem was that I didn't
think that there would be a toilet so I
didn't drink anything so I got quite
dehydrated is there a toilet there is a
toilet yes there were all these rumors
about what they wouldn't wouldn't be and
I didn't know so I've just made it very
safe oh those are things that normal
people don't have to not normal people
excuse me but like a normal wedding you
don't think will there be a bathroom and
then even weirder you think you don't
think and what happens if Oprah comes in
after like SWAT teams in the sewers and
things beneath where you're you know so
you kind of have to make provision for
all the craziness like did you know
people there did you did you speak to
anyone else do is like a royal for the
whole experience when you were walking
past if you look into drains to see if
you could see eyes
I was just I was super focused on just
not falling over
quite
[Music]